there's some trending news now here and
millions of people all of us we've spent
the past year working at home at some
point and many of us now meet virtually
but new technology is changing how we
interact online look at this
virtual meetings could soon look
something like that thanks to devices
like the microsoft hololens and google
glass
they make it possible to have a meeting
using virtual avatars
you can imagine we're brainstorming on a
on a new
movie you know attack of the hermit
crabs and there's oh look there's the
hermitcraft
space and we could storyboard out this
whole thing and collaborate in three
dimensions
i feel like that'd be a bit distracting
these devices are not available to the
public just yet
right now they're being sold to
developers who are experimenting
with how mixed reality can be used at
home work or
in the classroom eventually microsoft
wants to upgrade from avatars to
holoportation projecting a lifelike
image in a meeting doesn't that kind of
blow your mind it's so interesting